bon j'espère que tout le monde est en
appétit je voulais que notre première en
pleine cambrousse soit un peu moins
rustique il n'y a pas de pizza
là il n'y a pas de pizza c'est c'est
bien meilleur que de la pizza non rien
n'est meilleur que de la pizza et bien
moi je trouve que tout ça a l'air
absolument délicieux portons un poste à
ce beau projet ya ton expertise en
matière de nicholas k 1 fry santé à toi
santé l'élève ton père te revoir mais le
mec il annoncera sa coiffure ça tu vois
bien je les rencontrais dans la forêt
les gentils
je les appelais woody ne débarrasse de
lui d'après ce truc tommy tu ne sais pas
où ils allaient c'est moi qui ai aucune
idée d'où toi tu là prennent les mains
joly c'est un pivert presque apprivoiser
vervins monory sait très bien qui a
coupé le fromage et que ce soit c'est du
bon sens s'il te plaît faites cela
partie sous les guerres pizza cap ferrat
pas si j'ai fait voler vous n'avez pas
d'heure nous la carte au départ a tout
fait quelques passages en caisse avec
aux haricots aux légumes à mélomanes en
plus tu la manges amplitude
[Musique]
c'est dégoûtant moi je le trouve énorme
vous savez j'ai en ce sens une certaine
hostilité paris et arrêt qui fait de mal
à personne
c'est ce que j'ai dit je suis vraiment
navré est-ce que ça va ça va aller on va
déguster votre notre avenir
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
moderniser moix
[Musique]